[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui une question
relativement importante à savoir qu'elle
soit faire entre d'un côté la nouvelle
xbox one-x annoncé très récemment par
microsoft
et de ce côté-là ps quelques ronds de
sony qui est déjà sur le marché depuis
quelques temps et qui a fait ses preuves
on a deux côtés des produits qui sont
sensiblement dans la même gamme dans la
même typologie de produits qui sont
sensiblement similaires sans l'être pour
autant avec chacun alors leurs
spécificités
donc la question est quand on veut
acheter une nouvelle console quand on
veut s'équiper et quand on cherche à se
ressaisir
quels produits achetés entre cette xbox
onyx et cette ps4 pro alors le choix il
s'est très clairement déjà par rapport à
la fiche technique en terme de puissance
vous avez d'un côté avec la xbox onyx
une console qui est plutôt dédié à la
puissance très clairement on voit les
spécifications et cette console elle va
effectivement dans la recherche de
puissance pour exploiter gérer au mieux
la 4k
donc si vous êtes en recherche de
puissance on parle pas de pc gaming
si vous recherchez de la puissance sur
une console de salon très clairement la
xbox onyx et probablement pour vous
parce qu'elle va effectivement proposer
une expérience de jeu en terme de
qualité qui devrait être vraiment pour
l'instant incomparable sur des consoles
a contrario vous avez de l'autre côté la
ps4 pro qui est actuellement la console
la plus puissant du marché et qui à bon
nombre de points positifs
si on regarde juste sûr je dirais d'un
côté purement technique on compare un
peu les fiches techniques vous avez là
du côté de la xbox one 1,8 hors custom
qui est cadencé à 2,3 gigahertz contre
pour la ps4 pro1 x86 64 ème des jaguars
8 coeurs cadencé à 2,1 gigahertz un peu
moins puissant la différence à ce fait
vraiment au niveau de la carte graphique
vous a levé 6 téraflops pour la xbox one
x contre 4,2 téraflops pour la ps4 pro
la ram aussi il ya une vraie différence
d'à côté on va voir 12 giga octet
gddr5 pour la xbox aux knicks contre 8
gigas de l'autre côté pour la ps4 pro le
stockage ans elle même on est sur du
intérêts de chaque côté il ya une
différence qui se fait aussi au niveau
du lecteur
on est vraiment sur la 4k un haut niveau
de la xbox sonic son vote révèle donc un
lecteur 4/4 usd qui lie également les
bourgs et tandis que sur la ps4 au pas
de quatre cas on a un lecteur blu ray
dvd
si on regarde uniquement la fiche
technique on voit très bien que la xbox
one x mais une petite claque un petit
claque ou nette légère à la ps4 croquis
el pais même si pour l'instant est une
super console avec je dirais des
spécificités techniques qui se tiennent
vraiment elle est quand même légèrement
moins puissante
cette future xbox aux knicks si le choix
ne se fait pas par rapport aux
spécifications techniques
qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir effectivement
vous guider d'un côté ou de l'autre
alors il ya plusieurs choses et on va le
voir ensemble alors déjà il faut savoir
que sony a sorti sa ps4 haut il n'y a
pas longtemps la playstation 4 elle a
déjà quelques bonnes zones est derrière
elle et il ya une playstation 5 qui
serait prévu mais effectivement dans un
délai un peu plus long il se pourrait
bien il se pourrait c'est du
conditionnel que sony accélère la sortie
de sa ps5
tout simplement pour effectivement je
dirais se mettre au niveau voire au
dessus de cet ebook xbox one x en ce
moment le jeu vidéo se porte plutôt bien
on voit là la nintendo swiss 26 tout
autre chose qui a très très bien marché
qui a même cartonné en ce début d'année
la ps4 pro fonctionne plutôt pas mal je
pense que la xbox sonic va rencontrer
aussi un très gros succès donc si sony
ne veut pas cessé de vence et surtout
que là par console l'appart jeux vidéo
de sony et comme une activité phare chez
sony après il ya autre chose qui fait
vraiment la différence entre ces deux
produits toujours un point en terme de
puissance c'est effectivement le fait de
pouvoir avoir de la réalité virtuelle
sur la ps4 et notamment sur la ps4 pro
sept casques de réalité virtuelle même
si aujourd'hui c'est pas ce qui se fait
de mieux on sait très bien que l'oculus
chiffre est quand même au dessus du
casque vert que propose sony mais pour
l'avoir essayé je puis vous assurer que
si vous l'avez pas testé c'est vraiment
super les sensations sont justes
incroyable donc ça pour l'instant pas de
casque de réalité virtuelle chez
microsoft pour sa xbox aux knicks
c'est vraiment un peu le regret j'aurais
espéré que en même temps qu annoncé
cette cette fameuse console
il est en parallèle annoncé un casque de
verre et pourquoi pas un casque de
réalité virtuelle enquête casas aurait
mis une claque à tout le monde
peut-être que ça va être un produit qui
va être proposé en 2018 microsoft en
tout cas je l'espère parce que pour moi
la vr c'est vraiment l'avenir l'avenir
du jeu vidéo très clairement la vr la
réalité augmentée c'est vraiment des
choses qui sont juste extraordinaire
alors progresser encore un petit peu
techniquement mais en terme de
sensations c'est génial alors après la
xbox aux knicks
elle a vraiment un sens si vous utilisez
la 4k si vous avez un écran 4 cas si
vous êtes un gourmand où je dirais en
termes de technologie si vous n'avez pas
de télé quatre cas effectivement sur une
télé en full hd en 1080p vous aurez une
qualité qui sera effectivement
supérieure du moins c'est ce qu'a
annoncé microsoft mais par contre voilà
si vous n'avez pas je dirais l'ensemble
de la 4k l'ensemble du matériel quatre
cas ça reste un peu frustrant c'est une
console qui est pour proposer de la
vraie 4k de la 4k native
donc si derrière vous n'avez pas la télé
4k c'est dommage
c'est vraiment dommage et pour l'instant
tout le monde de très loin même n'est
pas encore équipé en téléviseur 4k
ce qui laisse présager encore un petit
peu de
de survie à la ps4 pro de sony parce que
la 4k
tout le monde ne l'a pas encore ça reste
quand même onéreux aujourd'hui de
s'équiper avec une nouvelle tv 4k
alors il ya une différence elle se fait
sur le prix la ps4
kroell et à 399 euros et la xbox aux
knicks à 499 99 centimes d'euro donc
c'est quand même une console qui est 100
euros plus cher que cette fameuse ps4
trop donc comme je le disais si vous
avez effectivement une délicate car vous
avez probablement investi et vous
souhaitez conserver puis avoir cette
qualité sur vos jeux vidéo ce qui est
complètement normal mais si vous n'avez
pas de télé 4k et si vous souhaitez
acquérir une nouvelle console
il ya quand même un delta de 100 euros
entre les deux produits ça se réfléchit
quand même la xbox aux knicks qui sera
disponible qu'à partir du 7 novembre
ça veut dire que si vous voulez cette
console si vous avez aujourd'hui son
projet d'acheter une console et que vous
voulez jouez vous avez un mois quand je
veux quand je veux quelque chose quand
je vois une console supporter des 34 5
mois là il va falloir attendre le 7
novembre
donc si vous avez un projet de vous
équiper à la rentrée pourquoi pas
attendre ici vous voulez jouer
rapidement il se peut que switch sur la
ps4 pro le catalogue et les accessoires
anciens que vous aviez sur les autres
xbox que vous allez pouvoir avoir sur
cette nouvelle xbox ces fameuses
rétrocompatibilité dont les gens qui
sont déjà clients chez microsoft et bien
vont pouvoir conserver leurs accessoires
ce qui est quand même pas mal parce que
ça coûte cher à la longue si vous avez
différents accessoires pour vous équiper
et puis vos jeux anciens sur lequel vous
avez encore du plaisir à jouer
vous allez pouvoir les conserver avec un
temps de chargement plus rapide
et puis un côté visuel et esthétique qui
sera quand même beaucoup plus sympas et
mieux exploité par la console mais
surtout la vraie différence à se faire
en fonction de vous en portant du choix
du consommateur
quels sont vos goûts quels sont les
licences exclusives que vous aimez de
quel est le jir et le
l'affinité que vous avez avec un produit
ou un autre une affinité avec une marque
ou l'autre souvent une console c'est une
aventure c'est une rencontre on a
commencé à jouer petit at-elle console à
tel jeu ça nous a marqués il ya une
vraie affinités qui sait avec la marque
donc dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez mais témoins tout en commentaire
et dites moi pour vous quelle est la
meilleure console entre la ps2 pro et la
xbox one-x même si effectivement il pas
sorti et on a tous des jeunes qui peu
entendu parler donc on s'est fait une
idée dessus qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ce que vous seriez prêt à sauter le pas
pour aller quérir la nouvelle xbox aux
knicks à partir du 7 novembre prochain
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
politique tarifaire
d'un côté comme de l'autre quels sont
les jeux qui vous tente
quelles sont vos attentes et à votre
avis qui remportera le match entre
microsoft et sony
merci d'abord regarder la vidéo je vous
invite à mener c'est un joli pouces
si ça vous a plu et si le contenu vous à
les intéresser et vous apporter les
éléments de réponse
merci à vous je vous dis à très très
très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo et
puis inscrivez-vous un chêne ses
contenus plaît et on parlera encore et
toujours de high tech d'innovation de
nouveautés et de pleins pleins d'autres
choses
à très bientôt et merci ciao
dans
à